can you believe we've gone through 20
episodes already well you know the drill
we've got more goodies for you from
strange facts about breath of the Wild's
2016 demo secret translations and
disarming enemies in weird ways if you
love this series let us know with a like
we guarantee you'll learn at least one
thing new today alright buckling
fans excited for the sequel tears of the
Kingdom have been laser focused on
anything related to the ancient zonai
including the strange zonai pillars
found in the official art book weird
thing is in the game it's just a simple
rock structure nothing unique or was it
believe it or not it wasn't always like
this in the breath of the wild Treehouse
E3 2016 demo they climbed this same
zonai Tower and it had these ancient
dragon designs on there then in the
final game it was removed for a simple
Rock Tower instead was it really that
much of a spoiler there are literally
hundreds of translatable chica texts all
around Hyrule you may have never noticed
while fans have translated everything in
the past I'll list some of the more
interesting ones that I like such as
when you first get the Chica slate the
game will state that the Slate is
damaged and nothing is in these tabs but
what's interesting is that the Chica
text on the top translates to album and
Hyrule compendium and when you repair
the shiko Slate at poora's lab you also
repair the text back into your native
language another weird one that pertains
to the Chica slate is when link updates
it using guidance Stones when you update
it a message will show above on the
stone which when translated shows a
repeating message Master using it and
you can have this which is a callback to
Zelda 1 where the old man will say this
strange message with the white sword or
the magic sword but that doesn't end
here did you know that it wasn't always
this message also in the E3 2016 demo
build it said something else entirely
which was now loading do not turn off
and all your bass are if you know older
memes you know exactly what this is this
refers to the 1989 arcade game zero wing
and the infamous meme all your base are
belong to us when you get the guardian
resist buff with ancient armor pieces
there's a symbol that shows up for it
it's for ancient in that final trial of
the Champions ballad there are four
locks surrounding the final door each
lock represents one letter w a f and E
this represents four elements varuto's
water far Meadows air barodonia's fire
and vonaburra's for Earth no this isn't
avatar The Last Airbender e stands for
electricity the dungeon that unlocks e
is Van Nu boris's element electricity
the Hyrule Castle Library also has a
neat detail pertaining to how the
library is categorized each Shelf has
two Hylian letters written on Top This
is an organizational system with the
first letter being a or b a referring to
the first floor and B being the second
floor and the second letter refers to
the alphabetical categorization such as
G through L on the second floor and E
through h on the first floor
they even considered the 100 Years of
degradation as a factor such as clearly
missing letters like the a shelf here
and the missing e-shelf here sitting
between dnf was completely taken out by
some Fallen debris crashing through the
library ceiling the very first 2014
reveal of breath of the wild previously
known as simply Zelda Wii U had a pretty
epic reveal trailer fans roughly put
together that this chase scene is very
much like the very first scene in
Princess Mononoke but that is definitely
not the only comparison did you see
something else here there are chica
Farmers out in the field here that are
pretty hard to spot with the basket on
their back this is very much a reference
to the amishi tribe in Princess Mononoke
who had the same hat clothing and basket
on their back cementing that this was
indeed Nintendo's Love Letter to Ghibli
Studios long before breath of the wild
was even finished this trailer also had
a pretty interesting ending the sound
effects used for link activating the
ancient Arrow was a completely custom
combination of in-game and custom sound
effects first the dismounting audio is
actually the first three thunderclaps of
a storm brewing sped up and Pitch
shifted
then of course the bullet time sound
effect
then a custom creaking sound of the back
of the ancient Arrow opening and the
bomb summoning sound effect at the same
time
then another custom sound effect for the
aeroshaft unfurling then the ancient
Arrow blade is actually the ancient
Arrow flying sound effect and lastly the
charge noise is the same
[Music]
that is a lot of sound effects for one
action when hesto is in the Lost Woods
have you actually taken a look at what
he's standing on he is actually standing
on a little Maraca Island
there's a funny detail at all the armor
shops in Hyrule above each shop is a
banner of the local clothing style from
traditional Italian clothing in hateno
Village chica garments in kakuriko
Village burrito outfit in Reno Village
and a garudo top piece in Gerudo town
and straight up just some metal
underwear and Goron City seriously man
some players still don't know that you
can hold any jump attack
[Music]
this can be done with swords two-handed
weapons and with Spears and it looks
pretty epic when done against enemies
players who started out after 2018 may
not remember this but Nintendo used to
put out articles for useful tips and
free items every week from August to
December 2017. director hide and Maro
fujibayashi gave out handy hints and
materials ranging from how to do the
extra selfie poses keeping yourself warm
with fire rods and how to saute some
nuts some players to this day have still
never encountered this situation but
have you ever seen Link holding a
flaming weapon while crouching it has a
completely unique animation specifically
for this and Spears have the advantage
with this in Tall Grass to keep the
flame away from yourself while two and
one-handed weapons will set yourself on
fire this can make some situations in
tall grass that can be pretty
entertaining
you've probably messed with this funny
interaction before sell me or rusts both
have metal or wooden Shields that can
make them a little angry if you try to
magnesis or burn them so there's
technically no way for link to steal it
but an enemy can by kiting an enemy to
Russ's location they can freely pick up
and take any shield with this you can do
some really weird things such as see the
shield snap back to its original
position if the enemy drops it burn it
out of the enemy's hands and make him
angry
or even buy The Shield right out of the
enemy's hands
[Music]
interesting business deal here
on the same topic many enemies in breath
of the wild of course can be disarmed
but did you know that it's possible to
disarm a Lionel
this is not just a visual bug when they
die they actually don't drop the weapons
they had equipped so by kiting a Lionel
all the way to Gerudo town
[Music]
then getting caught by the front guards
while the Lionel's in sight the Gerudo
guards confiscate the Lionel's weapons
as well the Lionel's AI doesn't really
work outside of his home range so kiting
it back will reactivate the Lionel sort
of
finals don't know how to Lionel without
their weapons so they kind of lose all
meaning in life
what was your favorite thing you learned
this time let us know in the comments
below we also still have an ongoing
playlist with the latest breath of the
wild content still coming so keep it
here on Gamespot
foreign